hey guys Pete here today I'm going to do
a preview of yellowjacket's season 2
episode 3. I'm going to be talking about
the promo trailer they put out some of
the other trailers that are out there
with stuff we haven't seen yet and there
are a ton of promotional photos from
episode 3 that I'll be touching on so if
any of that sounds like spoilers then
this video won't be for you I'm scared
Everything feels out of control
yeah
such an interesting design you draw on
her
an honor to meet you Mr the trailer
opens with Shauna telling Lottie that
she's scared and that everything feels
like it's out of control there's a shot
of what's left of Jackie's remains and
separate shots of teen Nat sitting on
the porch of the cabin and team Tai
freaking out by the fire pit with Van
there behind her to sort of comfort her
this would all seem like things that
happen in the aftermath of the Jackie
Feast of course we expect that they'll
have complicated feelings about what
they've done after the initial Buzz of
feeling full wears off as another shot
later where you can see several dead
birds on the roof of the cabin and all
around the yard based on the promo
photos I'm guessing that this might
happen shortly after the ending of
episode 2 and might add to their
uncomfortable feelings strange stuff
like this can happen but the number of
birds and the fact that they're all
around the cabin makes it seem pretty
spooky and so it's not really a stretch
to think that they might take that and
the guilt they're feeling and interpret
it as a sign there's a handful of shots
of them outside talking and you can see
a bird in one of those which makes me
think it's all connected and then there
are several shots of them crafting
together which could be an attempt to
ward off harmful forces in response to
all these Birds Thai is also
participating and to this point she's
been the loudest voice in opposition to
this kind of thinking so that might mean
it's related to something else or might
indicate that she's coming around to the
idea that Supernatural forces could be
in play which I guess would sort of be a
breakthrough for the character there's
another shot of the man with no eyes in
the trailer and of course he also made
an appearance in episode two I've always
interpreted Ty's resistance to these
ideas as a response to what's happening
to her and her not being able to
understand it or control it so it's
easier for her to say none of this stuff
exists you people are all crazy if she
is having a change of heart then the
question is why and the only thing that
I saw that could be related to that is
one of the promo photos you see that
Vans watching her sleep and they're not
tied together so she may be trying to
confront what's happening or they might
be trying to understand it together and
perhaps that would open the door to her
being a little bit more receptive to
some of this other stuff that's going on
one other thing before we move on from
Team tie it occurred to me when I was
making my video for episode two they get
up right from sleep to go out to see
what the smell is see what's going on
with Jackie's body that means there's a
definite possibility that she could be
sleepwalking I don't see anything that
would make me feel that way one way or
the other but remember whenever she bit
van in the previous episode there was
nothing to really say that she was the
bad one at that moment she looked pretty
normal so it's possible that she
participated in this and she won't be
able to deal with that just like they'll
all have trouble but she'll blame her
participation on the fact that she was
sleepwalking and maybe that leads to
some kind of Confrontation because
Shauna knows about her sleep walking
when she brings it up in season one but
it's not something that they talk about
it seems like van is the only one who's
really concerned with it thus far adult
Tai is at the hospital with Simone after
the crash and we hear a nurse or someone
there mention this interesting design
and then we see a shot of the symbol
drawn on her hand something we wouldn't
expect Ty to do in the present
necessarily she looks to be very tired
at least but also possibly surprised to
see it's there I co-hosted the Bald Move
podcast on episode 2 earlier today and I
asked Jim because my thought was that it
was probably the bad tie that took over
whenever the car crash happened and he
agreed with that based on the look that
she gave right before that happened and
when I saw this shot I thought about a
clip from one of the trailers where we
see her in the bathroom at the hospital
where we see that the reflection doesn't
match what she's doing indicating that
the bad one is there that there's two
people inside of her which of course we
know the symbol on Simone's hand is
interesting though because this could be
an indication that she uses that which
would change our perception of adult tie
but it seems more likely that she was
bad tie for some period of time she was
sleepwalking through at least part of
this and that's how that ended up there
after that we see Misty arriving at a
marina to meet up with putting the sick
in forensics meeting with Elijah Wood's
character for the first time I guess
he's a houseboat guy it looks like he
lives on a houseboat and it looks like
she tries to take control of the
situation saying that they have to get
one thing straight it's her case and her
witness and there's not much else to go
off of here that I didn't mention in my
last video but I'm still super excited
to see how this plays out there aren't
any promo photos of adult Misty but
there are two of her with Crystal where
they're having a conversation and it
looks like they're getting to know each
other it's a one-on-one and that made me
think of the clip from the trailer that
we haven't seen yet when she says she
has a secret a ginormous one I don't
know if we'll get get there in episode
three but I feel like that's a big thing
that's coming for these two characters
so they do need to set up their
relationship and how that's developing
there is a shot of nat returning to the
crash site it's notable that she's by
herself that Travis isn't there and
while she's inside of the plane she
hears a noise and it turns out to be a
caribou which it looks like she'll be
able to shoot the internet tells me it's
a caribou anyway I don't think a moose
is a bad guess but I saw a post saying
that it was more likely a caribou which
is smaller and that sounded good to me
this also shows up on the promo flyer
they sent out it looks like an
indication that they're gonna have some
food to last for a period of time I mean
it's a big animal so the bear lasted a
couple of months that might buy them a
couple more months maybe even get them
through winter or the really bad part of
winter until some of the animals come
back I think what is interesting about
this is that if it happens around the
time whenever they ate Jackie and these
birds all fell from this guy AI if
they're starting to get more Lottie
about it the way they see it and about
the Wilderness providing for them they
could interpret this as a sign that they
did something right and they're being
rewarded if you think back to the season
two official teaser and trailer there
was a sense that at least some of them
will adopt the idea that there was a
force guiding these things to happen
Natalie tells adult Lottie that she sees
a darkness and that they brought that
back with them team van is sort of
telling that story about a violent and
misunderstood Wilderness waiting to
befriend whoever arrived and then in
episode 2 we heard Travis's thoughts
about the wilderness coming for him
before he died a lot of this stuff feels
like it could be leading them in that
direction and we do think that there's
going to be a divide between them or at
least I do originally I thought it would
be the three survivors who stayed in
touch in season one on one side taishana
and Nat Nat is directly opposed to
Lottie right now in relation to Travis
but in this promo trailer we see Shauna
talking to Lottie she doesn't seem to be
too opposed we saw Lottie Overlook that
she had cut a piece off of Jackie when
she saw that before they burned the body
and like I said it looks like Ty is
there with the rest of them while
they're doing their crafting so it's all
pretty up in the air and I don't really
see anything here that looks like it's
going to happen right away there is a
shot of Shauna where it looks like she
has a bloody nose like it looks like
someone hit her but there aren't any
shots of that happening so I don't want
to jump to any conclusions there's also
a shot of Shauna carrying a gun and then
pointing it at someone while asking them
if they ever peeled the skin off a human
corpse there are a lot of photos of this
but none of them give a clear idea of
why she has the gun or what's happening
it appears that Jeff is with her before
this or after this because we do see a
shot with them together where she has
the gun but he's not in any of the ones
with this other character there is a
shot of her walking through a junkie
yard which maybe is connected to where
Adam worked remember he worked on cars
maybe this guy knows about her and their
relationship and she's trying to scare
him off that seems like the most likely
explanation and then there are a few
photos of Jeff talking to Kevin tan at
the gym for me this is the least
interesting thing that's happening in
the show right now so I don't have a lot
of ideas other than Shauna and Jeff
haven't done a great job of covering
things up they haven't done a great job
of talking to the police at least she
didn't and I expect that the heat on
them will continue to increase until
they figure out a way to get out of this
situation there are also a couple of
shots of hands one of char Jackie's
hands as far as I could tell and one of
adult lottie's hands covered in blood
there was another shot of this in a
previous trailer and I have no idea
what's happening in it there's something
there in front of her that appears to be
covered in blood it could be related to
this shot of her with the beehives but
I'm not sure how blood got there or what
it means in the promo fly are they sent
out it had the dead bird and you saw
some honeycomb design behind that so
that's what made me think about the
beehives in the promo photos there's
just one shot of her she's wearing these
same clothes and there's only one shot
of adult Nat who's still wearing what
she got when she was abducted because
she hasn't given into the heliotrope
clothing yet which made me laugh when I
saw it coach Ben doesn't show up in the
trailer but there is one shot of him in
bed not looking so good as I mentioned
in my episode 2 recap he has definitely
put himself in the out group of one for
not eating Jackie which means we'll be
watching to see if they start to treat
him differently and that's mostly it
with this big ending in the last episode
after the setup in the premiere it'll be
interesting to see where they focus
their attention I'm most interested to
see how they React to what happened and
how that divides them and who lines up
with who I do feel like a lot of this
stuff that's happening is going to make
people believe that Lottie is the person
person that they want to turn to when
things aren't making sense when they're
looking for some Faith some hope about
what's to come I thought they did a
great job of showing that through Travis
his relationship with Nat and how he's
still drawn to Lottie because he still
wants to hold on to that idea that hobby
might be okay and there's nothing to
indicate it here but I still am thinking
that hobby will show back up at some
point I don't know how that will happen
that should introduce a whole new aspect
to whatever's going on out there so that
might not be until later in the season
and I think that's a good place to leave
things today I'll try to come back next
week and do another preview and of
course I'll be doing a in-depth
breakdown again for episode three after
it's out like this video If you enjoyed
it please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already and thanks for watching
and I'll talk to you soon